la mallette Santos jamais de la vie
l'amour
siècle ça fait longtemps que je suis pas
heureuse je quitte la ville ça tombe
bien parce que moi aussi tu veux aller
où toi
on vient pour la voiture attendez vous
avez demandé une livraison à thalassi et
là c'est de gonzesses sont débarqués en
disant qu'elles allaient être à l'aise
elle se charge de conduire à votre place
ça vous embête ça se pourrait
si elle tombe sur la coulée
je comprends que vous soyez contrarié
monsieur on va récupérer le colis vous
l'aurez bientôt je vais t'aider à
élucider un meurtre j'ai jamais rien
entendu d'aussi con et je suis flic je
te rappelle qui êtes-vous
[Musique]
et ben c'était une grosse journée